[موسيقى]
عرف بعبقريته وطيبته وتواضعه للناس ولقب
بابي الوراثه العربيه
البروفيسور والطبيب والعالم الفلسطيني
احمد الطيبي
ولد في العام
انهى تعليمه الثانوي في مدارس الكويت
واظهر نبوغا في الشهر والرسم ولكنه نزل
على رغبه ابيه في دراسه الطب فدرس هذا
التخصص في جامعه القاهره
عاد بعدها الى الكويت ليعمل طبيبا وسافر
بعدها الى دبل لاكمال تخصصه العلمي ثم حصل
على الماجستير في الطب الوراثي من جامعه
لندن وكذلك حصل على الدكتوراه من الجامعه
ذاتها في تخصص طب الاطفال والامراض
السريريه
بعد حرب الخليج الثانيه عمل الطيب في احد
المستشفيات في الولايات المتحده قبل ان
ينتقل الى كندا حيث عمل استاذا في جامعه
ماجيال في مدينه مونتريال وواصل هناك
ابحاثه العلميه
لاحقا عين استاذا في كليه الطب ورئيسا
لقسم الاطفال في جامعه تورنتو
نشر الطيب اكثر من 200 بحث في مجال علم
الوراثه والامراض الوراثيه واشار الى 38
نوعا جديدا من الاضطرابات الوراثيه
والجينيه الجديده كما انه قام بالعديد من
الابحاث الاخرى على قوانين مندل الوراثيه
وكان عضوا بارزا في العديد من المجلات
المتخصصه في علوم الوراثه والجينات في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عمل البروفيسور احمد الطيبي 30 عاما في
تاسيس علم الوراثه العربي وتركز تبحث على
الاضطرابات الوراثيه عند الاطفال العرب
والف كتابا عن الاضطرابات الجينيه بين
الشعوب العربيه ونشر هذا الكتاب عام
1997 عن مطبعه جامعه اكسفورد
نالت ابحاث الطيب غير المسبوقه جوائز عده
منها جائزه مؤسسه الكويت للتقدم العلمي
كما اسهم باكتشاف عدد كبير من الجينات
المتنحيه التي تدرس الى يومنا هذا في
الجامعات الغربيه وحصل على جائزه من فرنسا
عام 2001 عن ابحاثه التي مكنته من تحديد
عدد من الامراض الوراثيه
عضويه الاكاديميه الاوروبيه للعلوم تقديرا
لجهود الطبيه
توفي عام 2010 بعد معاناه طويله مع المرض